I would like just to to to emphasize
this in a very clear manner that
unfortunately we find ourselves time and
again years after years in the same
position without any
progress that while we defend the right
for someone to speak their mind to draw
whatever they want
we are not willing to respect the
feelings of almost two billion people
around the
world so that is care of course it's one
of the biggest Muslim organizations in
the world they had a chance to speak out
on the terror attacks in France to
denounce it they didn't Charlie hido
says we are facing a modern-day Nazism
knowing a lot of people don't seem to
see it that way nonetheless they have
been forced to wake up and address the
elephant in the room they admit are now
at war with Jihad and are increasing
their presence against Isis let's bring
in Robert Spencer of Jihadi watch good
to have you sir this morning thank you
good to be here I want to get your
reaction to car's reactions you know
they play very big to moderate Muslims
and the mainstream media you know for
whatever reason trust care I'm not sure
why they don't look Beyond uh the
headlines to know that they have
possible links to uh the Muslim
Brotherhood according to uh government
but you know here's an organization that
is said to represent moderate Muslims
and that message that they spewed
yesterday does not condemn Terror in
fact it you know he's talking it on both
sides of his mouth oh absolutely he says
he's for freedom of expression but then
he says that uh there has to be respect
for the feelings of what he says are two
billion people around the world almost
two billion which is probably almost a
billion exaggerated but in any case uh
he's saying that they have to be there
has to be respect for their feelings
which means that he respects the freedom
of expression except he doesn't he wants
the West to voluntarily curtail its
freedom of expression in order to
respect Sharia blasphemy laws and to
adopt in effect those Sharia blasphemy
laws that place Islam above criticism
sure so in other words we respect your
freedom as long as it's on our terms but
yet you know the mainstream media and
those who say the Muslim Community needs
to you know work with us to address
these uh rooted issues you know we are
lulled into this false sense that
something is being done when actually
it's not absolutely yes uh and nothing
is actually being done except for an
ongoing battle by the organization of
Islamic cooperation which is 57 Muslim
governments around the world and groups
like the Hamas link Council on American
Islamic relations that uh are they they
have been working for years to compel
the West to restrict its freedom of
speech to criminalize what it calls in M
to religious hatred which is obviously a
very vague term that can be EXC any can
be interpreted in any number of ways and
the person who has the power to
interpret it has enormous authority to
determine what is acceptable speech and
what isn't and of course what care and
the OIC want to do with that is to
essentially criminalize all criticism of
Islam for care to say that they're in
favor of free speech it's ludicrous
they've been enemies of free speech for
years demonizing and smearing anyone and
everyone who dares to raise a voice
against Jihad Terror in any way trying
to get them shut down marginalized so
that nobody will will touch them in the
Public Square get them canceled from
speaking engagements this is a group
that is relentlessly against the freedom
of speech and it's all in service of the
same goal to impose these blasphemy laws
of it from of Islam sure but in the days
you know on the day that charl hido put
out its it its you know first response
after the terror attacks some bizarre
things are happening you got the UK
Banning authors from using
in in in children's books you've got the
pope now saying you know we believe in
freedom of speech except you know not on
religion and then you know you've got uh
you know France arresting 54 people who
are said to be supporting terrorists and
I say haven't we learned anything in the
last week no as a matter of fact Alex
you're absolutely right what these
things that you list off amount to is
that the terrorists have won the Charlie
hebo attack was successful the West is
in free PA Western media Outlets I I was
very pleased to see as this show is
going on that the cover of the latest
edition of Charlie hebo was shown here
and that it has a cartoon of Muhammad uh
this is something that most western
media Outlets did not have the courage
to do every newspaper and every TV news
show in the world should have shown
those cartoons in the wake of this
attack to show that we're going to
defend the freedom of expression as the
bullwark of a free Society but instead
most of them surrendered most of them
declined to do so you have Western
leaders like the pope and others saying
we should voluntarily restrict our
freedom of speech which is exactly what
NAD was saying and so they won they
succeeded in doing what they wanted to
do they have made it a they've
stigmatized criticism of Islam and it's
on its way to being outlawed yeah look
there are very few of us in the media
who are showing the cartoons and or the
response by Charlie heo we are doing it
as Sun News uh but there are many who
aren't because they're simply cowing but
I don't understand how you tell this
story this news story I watched my
colleagues last night talk about the
controversy of a new cover of Charlie
heo and yet they didn't show it and so
it's disingenuous because in the news
business we do shocking things that are
offensive all the time we have to make
decisions all the time but we have to
protect what news is and continue
forward even it if it offends people
precisely and the story here should be
the fact that this is even a problem and
that uh there is a risk now a risk of
physical danger because of this the the
focus should be on the outrage that this
is that we have to that we are even
there's even a question of succumbing to
this violent intimidation and thuggery
and instead people are just acquiescing
to it as if it were uh an ordinary thing
so let's talk about France and its
response to this do you get the sense
this is or should have been I think a
turning point and I know that France has
increased its strikes against Isis you
know it's moved ships into into the
region um I I get the sense that they
want to respond but you know the
directions of the White House certainly
say otherwise yes absolutely uh the the
response has been tepid at best I mean
the the the uh ideology is not being
addressed nobody is standing up and
saying uh that in anything like the
numbers of people who are saying that we
ought to restrict our freedom of speech
and stop offending these these delicate
sensibilities of these Jihad murderers
uh nobody stand up in those numbers and
saying uh wait a minute we ought to be
saying you guys are crazy this is
ridiculous these are cartoons grow up
and understand in a larger sense that in
any pluralistic society we all have to
put up with being offended without
resorting to violence Iraq has written a
letter to President uh Barack Obama uh
saying that the us-led Coalition against
Isis is not working in fact they are
emboldened in moving forward do you get
the sense that uh Mr Obama will increase
you know this mission he might be forced
to by uh the sheer political pressure
that he uh is under if that is the
opposition can muster that pressure but
uh there's no doubt that the Iraqi
government is absolutely right the air
strikes have been completely ineffective
they're just really political window
dressing to show that he's doing
something but there's no chance that
they're going to dislodge the Islamic
State by themselves and the problem is
he's going to have to put ground troops
back in Iraq if he wants to get rid of
the Islamic State and then he's got the
Perpetual problem that as long as the
troops stay there there may not be this
kind of activity in this at least in
this to this extent but as soon as they
leave it will start up again and so it's
it's it's a dilemma but it's even worse
for Obama since he had troops there and
withdrew them so precipitously and
without due consideration of what might
come in their aftermath but this is this
very same scenario is now playing out in
Afghanistan he's been warned that Isis
has now moved in there the Taliban you
know like they want to a caliphate
Afghanistan into Pakistan and so what's
he going to do will he continue
withdrawing troops just to fulfill a
campaign promise yeah I would expect so
because uh there's still no appreciation
no significant appreciation in the
western media of the implications of
what might come next we're watching it
we just saw it happen in France we
watched it in Canada we saw it in
Australia that's what happens exactly
and there's going to be more of that
plus the possibility as you say that a
caliphate could be established in
Afghanistan and Central Asia that could
actually meet up with the Islamic State
and become a very very significant
geopolitical entity yeah I can't wait to
see what happens when they seize
Pakistan nukes it'll be a really
wonderful day all right Robert I gota
leave it there it's a pleasure thank you
Robert Spencer joining us of Jihadi
watch this morning